not in Texas where a conservative
federal judge May soon issue a ruling
that would block access to a
long-approved abortion pill Nationwide
the pill has been available for two
decades and it's the most common method
of abortion in the United States
Christina raffini is outside the
courthouse in Amarillo Texas Christina
good morning
good morning access to this case was
extremely limited fewer than 40 seats in
the courtroom and no publicly available
live stream or audio feed for a case
that could have wide-ranging nationwide
implications
a handful of pro-abortion Rights
demonstrators stood outside the federal
courthouse in Amarillo access to
medication abortion is one of the last
options that we have while inside an
anti-abortion Rights group called The
Alliance for Hippocratic medicine argued
the court should reverse the FDA
approval for the drug miva Preston the
medication approved up to the 10th week
of pregnancy is part of a two-step
medical abortion process that makes up
53 percent of abortions in the United
States the organization made its case in
front of Judge Matthew kasmarek a trump
appointee that the FDA incorrectly
approved the drug through an accelerated
process and said it presents a danger to
women the FDA says the drug which has
been used in the United States for more
than two decades went through a rigorous
four-year approval process and says 99
of patients are treated without an
adverse reaction is that the goal to
make it harder to get an abortion for
women that's definitely not the goal
Johnson zigo is the president of Texas
right to life but when the FDA looks at
what their job is they need to start
over and they need to do the due
diligence on this abortion-inducing drug
the drug is currently available by mail
even in states where abortion is illegal
but this decision could impact its
availability Nationwide it could have
Ripple effects in every state not just
in states that want to ban abortion
now during the hearing the judge
appeared to issue questions that seemed
sympathetic towards the anti-abortion
Rights group but didn't say anything to
reveal his position Adriana he says he
hopes to have his decision as soon as
possible
Christina thank you